all right so put your hands together for
team 13.
all right thank you
leadership for tomorrow depends on how
we educate our students today especially
in science technology engineering and
math president obama september 2010
stem based jobs are expected to grow two
times as fast as any other jobs
one million additional stem related
grads are needed over the next 10 years
but the pipeline is small and we're not
capturing a large enough group to meet
that need
by broadening the pipeline
by engaging in engaging students in stem
early we can make it by making it fun by
making it interesting and appealing to a
larger group
we can connect them and increase and
capture more people in the pipeline more
students in the pipeline
our idea connect middle school students
with ingenium
our shipping container filled with tools
supplies all the stuff that you might
just find around
and this
is designed in such a way that it allows
students to design develop prototype
solutions to the challenges that they
want to tackle making stem relevant
interesting and expanding the number of
students in the pipeline
how does it work
the students identify or the community
members identify local issues
we worked to curate those projects
and the and through the curation process
the
um
the students and the teachers work to
select what those projects might be and
then the container is dropped off uh
once that particular community that once
that particular school is selected
the unique features of this is that
we're targeting middle middle school
students and again these are the middle
school students that are um able to uh
to would be interested in tackling the
project low cost shipping container is
about approximately three thousand
dollars the stuff inside very low tech
community involves the community it's
scalable
and um in terms of timing uh we can load
up and roll this out in about a month
great thank you just come on over
all right team 14 where you at
container-based
so the containers are meant to be filled
with just art with with stuff that we
aren't afraid to be uh not afraid to be
broken so they're not they're very low
tech plastic bottles wires um anything
that you might find around so again
we're trying to keep the cost down uh
very low tech things that's that that
we're not afraid of of students breaking
and um and as i said the shipping
containers are about three thousand
dollars
and how would they find out about it
who would make them who would buy this
and how would they find out about it so
that's part of our funding uh model so
we've talked about many things whether
it be um you know uh recruiting
corporate sponsorship and um uh you know
perhaps uh connecting into organizations
like you know the national science
foundation and others um
and i don't know do you guys want to add
teachers be able to use these the stuff
in the container
yes i mean how how are they prepared are
they do they hope is actually to
get maybe graduate students studying
design to help facilitate this container
so they know their design process so
they come in they're the ones who do all
the sort of curriculum planning up front
they know how to run the process so for
the teachers
they're not paying for the materials
they're not doing any curriculum
planning we're trying to make it easy
for them
so
you know the students or someone in the
community submits these ideas we curate
them say this is a great problem we want
to figure out you know how do we use
this empty lot in the community
we come in and we work with the students
to sort of help them develop solutions
for that
is it a rental model like the container
comes for a certain amount of time or is
it a permanent model yes we're trying to
figure out what the right time frame is
and and steve suggested three weeks is
probably a good time frame and i think
it's something you would probably
prototype and try to figure out you know
because hey one question is how long do
we have the students for on a day-to-day
basis are they there for the whole day
or just a couple of hours
i
and i think that the idea was that we
were imagining it uh leaving it there
for three to four weeks to allow time
for the stu for the the students in the
the school to feel ownership and then
move it off to the next